foreign
of facts are your friends
to something oh sweet
get out your Marlboro Reds and your bush
tall boys
now don't get any of that stuff out
it'll just make you feel bad tomorrow
I'll make it make you feel bad right now
all right so facts of your friends I'm
doing a hostile takeover of facts of
your friends today sorry Kelly Shake It
Off
um James sent me James child's the old
producer of the show that Kelly like
dude it was Hunger Games and she got rid
of him hostile takeover is dope
um he forwarded me an email the other
day
um he's still employed he's got a job
he's doing fine
this is incredible listen to this
a lawsuit has been filed in Canada this
is from Fox News
a lawsuit has been filed in Canada by
parents who say their kids are addicted
to the video game fortnite
a Canadian Supreme Court Judge
authorized a filing by Quebec parents
against their manufacturer parents say
their kids are addicted so so addicted
that they don't take care of regular
everyday hygiene such as showering
some kids are so dependent on fortnite
they stopped eating and sleeping
according to BBC News and reported by
Insider
this gives me hemorrhoids at a level
that preparation age simply can't help
it's fun it's
phenomenal to me that this is a thing
happening on the planet right now this
is happening on the planet right this
second
um the attorney who brought the suit
equated the games maker the people who
created and and produced fortnite with
tobacco manufacturing let's let's end
apart for a second because that's stupid
and you've heard me on this show I think
the people behind big tobacco were evil
people behind some of the big food
companies are evil because they're
taking
products and they are hiding
uh number one they're taking products
that they are handing to adults
and who then hand them to their children
and they say hey we've done all the
testing on these These are super safe
and not only are they safe look at our
package they're good for you they help
out with things if you go back to the
original cigarette manufacturers
cigarettes were something that helped
calm you down it helped it menthol
cigarettes cigarettes were good for
pregnant women right this is nonsense
like that and so when they got the
reports that hey everyone's getting
cancer and dying they hid those reports
and they lied about them that's evil
you also have heard me say I think video
games are a Scourge on Humanity I don't
like them I do know a lot of people that
play and they're great human beings and
I actually like playing Mike Tyson's
punch out still the greatest game ever
and Metroid from the original Nintendo
legit game
um
and I might get my kids a system at some
point fine
but here's the deal
I'm the parent
and if my 12 year old is so focused on a
particular thing carrots Pizza
cigarettes a video game I'm the parent
it's my job to intervene and if that
means smashing the video game systems
and cutting all the cords to the Wi-Fi
to the to the high-speed internet coming
into my home then that's what I do
because I'm a parent
I am Mom and Dad
cut the cord I also know that if I cut
the cord that means I got to do more
parenty things
that are really annoying and that hurt
because I'm tired I'm exhausted
but the idea that I just can't control
what's in my house and I just don't know
my kids no
parents here's the dopest thing about
Electronics
and I didn't know this there's a button
on the side and it says off and you can
just push it and it goes off it turns
off
you can take the controllers and set
them on fire making it impossible to
play
I don't for a second believe that
fortnite or whatever video games are not
addictive I'm confident they are I bet
we could do a deep dive into some of the
literature that they have some of the
studies they've done on how to get kids
to play more how to get people playing
these games to play them more often with
different fonts and different lights and
withholding things in certain intervals
I'm confident that exists
but I'm more confident that it's the
parents responsibility to keep their
kids safe and if your kid is unable to
shower or eat or sleep
because they're so entrenched in a thing
as a parent it's your job
to intervene to keep your kids safe and
intervention is not lobbying grenades at
some video game maker they're doing
their job quite frankly their job is to
get you to play more of their product
cool
cool here's what I love
um they go
the the the the makers of the game go on
to say parents can receive playtime
reports that track the amount of time
their child plays each week and
they can require parental permission
before purchases are made in the game
so the company is not saying hey play
less they they can't say that because
that's their they lose their job but
they're saying hey parents we've even
built in ways for you to participate in
this
here's the thing
at some point at some point
moms and dads we've got to step up and
step into these situations
and stop completely abdicating
responsibility to raising her kids to
third-party people
whether it's a video game or a school or
a youth group or a church whatever I've
got to be present in my kids lives and
if your kids want to play I don't know
what fortnite is I don't know anything
about it but if they want to play it
knock your lights out I don't know maybe
is it is it unhealthy game is it a bad
game for kids
no it's one it actually is one of the
ones my son used to play it he doesn't
anymore but it requires some thought
process and you have to knock your
lights out great great
um yes play play video game it's fine
but it's up to you as the parent to
regulate it and how much time they're
spending on it and who they're
participating with and are they being
groomed for in-person encounters by
people that you don't want your kids
around that's your job your job I also
want a shout out if you're a single
single mom or a single dad and you're
working four jobs
and this is a way for you to breathe I
get that man I get that's hard
like hey my kid there's an overlap
between my work shifts my kid goes home
he plays fortnite for a few hours and
that gives me that gives me a gap
and cover I get it I get it
I'm gonna ask you to reconsider
I'm going to ask you to reconsider using
digital babysitters as a proxy for
Parental intervention or as a less risky
Endeavor than
any number of other behaviors we can put
in front of our kids
I guess what I'm asking for is let's
stop blaming people
I'm gonna start taking responsibility
for the children inside our homes
and that starts with
using the off button starts with saying
no it starts with telling our kids you
can't do that because it's not safe it's
not good for you
that's what parenting is